it's been a long time since Peter
Jackson dazzled moviegoers with his
award-winning blog post a trilogy
adaptation of JRR Tolkien's the Lord of
the Rings and although Jackson followed
that up with his Hobbit series the stars
behind photos quest to pig the ring to
Mordor have changed quite a bit since
original Lord of the Rings films here's
what the people of middle-earth have
been up to since the one ring to rule
them all was tossed into the fire Elijah
Wood
before he became Frodo Baggins Elijah
Wood was a well known child star who had
appeared in movies like Radio Flyer and
the good son but Lord of the Rings
helped to jettison the actor into the
Fulham mainstream
after that he started having roles in
films like Sin City and Eternal Sunshine
of the spotless mind in addition to
returning to The Hobbit in 2012
he's also continued to star on the big
screen as well as television he recently
appeared in BBC America's Dirk gently's
holistic detective agency and the stars
and Netflix's I don't feel at home in
this world anymore what badasses now
we're big badass Sean Astin perhaps best
known for his role as photo's right-hand
man a Samwise Gamgee actor Sean Astin no
longer looks like The Hobbit who made
him famous like Elijah Wood Astin was
also known for the roles he played as a
young man in films like The Goonies and
a Rudy long before he ever set foot in
the Shire however his post Lord of the
Rings career it's a little less busy
he's landed a few small roles in movies
and television series but nothing's
managed to stick just yet he may enjoy a
career turn around though after
appearing in the much-anticipated second
season of Netflix of stranger things
Ian McKellen in arguably the most
decorated of all the Lord of the Rings
cast members Sir Ian McKellen looks even
wiser now than he did with the stuff in
his hand
afterward Gandalf the actor continued to
enjoy his prominent role in the x-men
movies and the most recently played
Cogsworth in Beauty and the Beast and
the title role of King Lear on stage he
also remains one of the staunchest and
most influential advocates of LGBT
rights Sean Bean whether or not you had
sympathy for Boromir Sean beans next
high fantasy character would suffer a
PHA that broke the hearts of millions
and then formed an entire series of
family vengeance although Bean has also
enjoyed roles in major movies like stroy
Nacional
treasure and the Martian he may be best
known these days for a short-lived turn
as Ned Stark on HBO's Game of Thrones
he's been gone from the show for several
seasons but his face was not being
forgotten by the people of Westeros
telling the North Memphis Sean Bean have
since capitalized on that small-screen
attention and nabbed roles in shows like
missing legends and broken Viggo
Mortensen becoming the king of Gondor
was certainly the big break of Viggo
Mortensen have been waiting for but it's
not just a fine role by any stretch of
the imagination the actor has since
impressed in films like a history of
violence the road Eastern Promises and
Captain fantastic and mourn sooner since
branched out into artistry as well
founding a publishing company and
creating his own poetry books and
paintings he's also known to have rocked
out with Bucky head producing multiple
albums of the avant-garde guitarist
Orlando Bloom after appearing at the
elven Archer Legolas Orlando Bloom
earned instant heartthrob status and
prime placement in several other
blockbusters including Troy and the
Pirates of the Caribbean series he also
made at least one error in job judgment
by starring in the critically maligned
Elizabethtown come on despite the
setback a Bloom has continued to ride
the wave of franchises that have
informed his career over the past two
decades by picking back up his bow for
the Hobbit trilogy and appearing in the
latest pirates pick Liv Tyler also
earning heartthrob status in Lord of the
Rings was Arwen the elven love interest
of Aragorn
nowadays Liv Tyler has managed to break
away from her fantastic image and status
as the daughter of Aerosmith Steven
Tyler to forge a career or her own
formerly a teenage model Tyler got her
acting start in the mid 90s appearing in
films like Empire Records and Armageddon
and has since continued to amass an
impressive resume
most recently appearing in HBO's the
leftovers as the terrifying cult leader
meg dominic monaghan
mary might have been the most serious of
the shire-folk but in real life Dominic
Monaghan is about as laid-back as they
come the animal lover is a vocal
advocate for nature even earning his own
show about tracking down rare species of
animals and insects and even though he
was part of the Lord of the Rings
fellowship he may be
- known for his heartbreaking work on
the small screen series lost Billy Boyd
unlike most of his co-stars the man who
played Pippin took in the Lord of the
Rings movies hasn't become a Hollywood
staple rather Billy Boyd is more of a
musician than a thespian these days he
did appear alongside Russell Crowe in
Master and Commander and starred in
several Indies but he's also the lead
singer guitarist for a band called be
cake that musical prowess has come full
circle for him and he wrote and
performed the end credits scene for the
Hobbit the Battle of the five armies
John Reith Davis in addition to being
known for his axe swinging skills as a
dwarf Gimli Jean Rhys Davis is also
recognizable as the man who starred a
seller in the Indiana Jones films and
like his dwarf counterparts the actor
would have no trouble singing over a
Ledge because in real life he's over six
feet tall he can currently be seen in
another fantasy series called the
shannara chronicles' Hugo Weaving
although he might be remembered for his
turn as Lord Elrond in Lord of the Rings
Hugo Weaving face is probably even more
associated with the matrix since he
starred as the inescapable Agent Smith
in that trilogy as well he also enjoyed
crime placement and picks like a V for
Vendetta
Captain America the First Avenger and
the most recently hacksaw bridge weaving
will also reteam with Peter Jackson to
act in 2018 s mortal engines capable
unsheathe the fabulous actress behind
the elven Queen Galadriel needs no
introduction shortly after the Lord of
the Rings trilogy ended Cate Blanchett
when her first two Academy Awards for
The Aviator after that she had no
trouble nabbing roll after roll on the
big screen
notable highlights includes notes on a
scandal Hannah and blue Jasmine the film
that earned her a second Oscar for
herself she's also joined Hugo Weaving
in the Marvel bad guy club as a villain
hella in thor ragnarok and as she said
to appear in the gender bent Ocean's
eleven spin-off ocean's 8 David Wenham
after becoming Faramir for Lord of the
Rings David Wenham went on to star in
300 as well as other films and small
screen series most recently when M
starred in BBC's top of the lake and
Netflix as Marvel series Iron Fist and
he's also steps behind the lens to make
his directorial debut with ellipses
thanks for watching click the Lupo icon
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you're nothing
[Music]